the Joe Rogan experience there was a
time when I was I was going through a
phase where I dropped my pants on stage
oh you stop doing that I did people
start to complain why I don't know how
much this is the oldest comic gig in the
[ __ ] gig and the thing it's just a
gag you drop your pager Lewis is funny
did you have underwear on yeah oh yeah
are you
Ahri's pulls his hog out not anymore
it's really scared can you do that isn't
it a you put your hog out he pulled his
hog out at a skank fest
in New York they had a you know skank
fest again I don't not familiar get in
the loop I know I'm out of it did a few
weeks ago that killed Tony yeah let's
talk out yeah yeah right before he was
here I before it maybe Tony was here one
of the times where was it oh well
probably shouldn't say that that could
probably be Rob what wasn't barely legal
well I used to do it just a rubber dick
don't worry about it folks I used to do
it yeah and then nobody noticed that I
was embarrassing yeah Joe Joe sometimes
I do jokes alright okay what am I here
with my father no it's okay it's all
fine it's all fine ari uh has always
done ridiculous [ __ ] he used to go on
stage with his balls out of his pants
not address it so go onstage and do his
act and when you do he would just unzip
his pants pull a sack out and then just
have only a sack did it at the store
where there's like someone onstage Joey
bombing and yes Joey bomb it was a woman
on stage she was terrible like one of
the worst comics has ever done comedy
and this one night she was killing I
mean [ __ ] killin and this is why when
she would hit a punchline
Joey was hiding behind the stage and he
was naked there you go close the
curtains and so she would get this giant
[ __ ] laugh and she was like wow she's
like and then I told him [ __ ] you know
yes balls ask naked and would that seems
like be in jail that seems criminal with
Joey's balls look like grapefruit and an
old lady's pantyhose and he's got a
giant dick so Joey would you know
he's got this huge belly so he opens up
the curtains his pants are down by his
ankles his balls ins dick or hanging out
it's get this huge belly yeah she never
did comedy again really no okay she
should have larious that's in Austin
actually that was where we were at the
hotel hanging out in the that's our in
the background yeah hanging out at the
jacuzzi getting ready for the show Wow
yeah day that I mean like comedies it's
already dangerous enough yeah I don't
need to add nudity well you get in
trouble now yeah it's like that like
people can get really angry at you for
showing your deck well that could it's
not not like the olden days it's kind of
it was a subtle gag it's a good we could
see it yeah nobody cares guys yeah you
Joey used to do it all the time
yeah I don't there was I remember when I
was a kid I had older sisters and they
there was a flasher in our neighborhood
they were going like oh the kite-flying
I'm like I don't understand this whole
thing I understand why he's doing that I
don't understand why it freaks you out
so much it's like I don't the whole
thing but I do not know I understand why
it freaks them I get the freaking out I
still don't get why they do it but I
think it has something to do with
someone traumatizing you when you're
young it's cut yeah it's gotta be
humiliation something you're addicted to
that kind of it there's lots of people
like that yeah well how about guys who
are addicted to they hire women to gag
them and [ __ ] on them and kick him in
the balls and yeah sometimes like really
powerful man hurt them yeah yeah hurt
that stomped or not like stop on their
nuts with a stiletto and that starts
bleeding how is that fun how is that
what is that I don't know that is such
an peep that is broke such so down a
rabbit hole of you million I'm you know
I mean I was hit a lot as a guy with the
cap let's go all the guilt and hitting
and fight and somehow managed to avoid
that kind of that kind of don't have
weird [ __ ] but that's a mommy [ __ ] and
like the whole pantyhose and beating you
and kicking in the ball so it's like
there's obviously it's gotta be my realm
of pathologies that people can develop
in their life and it's probably a lot of
mental illness involved in there and
violence and abuse
but apparently there's a woman that I
talked to who's a dominatrix and she was
telling me and Jim Norton you know Jim
hydrogen in a dominant he loves
dominatrix and she was saying most of
her clients are like these like wealthy
CEOs and they run these companies and
they're the [ __ ] man and when they
walk in Oh mr. Wilson's here hello mr.
Wilson can I get you a cup of coffee and
everyone's kissing her ass and they want
someone to [ __ ] on him like literally
[ __ ] on him they want someone to tie him
up and she yeah she would say that those
are the guys why is that though I guess
it's just so every powerful guy wants to
like feel a release of their power well
that's why when the John Wayne [ __ ] on I
don't get it maybe the steel dossier
right when they're talking about Trump
getting peed on all that stuff or peeing
on them that's why it made sense it's
like well of course of course
what not that it's real now I'm gonna
made sense of its real but that would be
a story because you expect from a super
powerful guy who had a weird kink super
powerful guys with weird kinks they
usually want to get pegged right they
want to get pissed on pegged is the best
that's one that's one of the best things
like cuz you could say pegged on
national TV right now yes still you can
still say pegged no one can stop you
right peg does not like it's not in the
dictionary I don't think right if you
say butt [ __ ] with a dildo people go
hey but you shouldn't even say that
because it's too wordy the economy of
words pegged fits better and it's it's
it's got a P and a G pegged how do you
just not start laughing when they when
she starts pegging you I don't know how
do you just not start laughs might be
really into it I'm a bad boy what are
the women get out of it did you get to
dominate you and that's it humiliate you
yeah I knew a guy in this group girl
said that she would [ __ ] him if if if he
let her peg him and he wouldn't do it
oh really we're calling he wanted to do
it yeah well she said she was I'll let
you [ __ ] you me hug me but I want to
[ __ ] you in the ass
how real is she she's pretty hot and all
my friends called him gay well bro are
you gay eight you should have just
[ __ ] her and literally someone [ __ ]
you in the ass you're gay and my friend
it was funny he was like it's not even a
real dick bro
[Laughter]
there's no win there yeah she probably
doesn't want to [ __ ] you but she's
willing to do it if you willing to do
something for her she probably always
wanted a peg a guy you got to make some
sacrifices yeah it's like your joke
about the the female version of who
wants to give you a job in Hollywood
movie
Oh Harvey no Weinstein yeah yeah Harvey
Weinstein came to my son with a solid
contract I'd be like dude you're gonna
be Batman
[Applause]